okay so i wanted to speak some more
about this topic of proving
approximation guarantees for
game theoretic equilibria and uh so i'm
going to start by just reminding you
where we left off where the story was
last time when we were talking about
games of incomplete information and
extension theorems for bayes nash
equilibria i'll also fill in a couple of
the missing details just because they're
so simple i want you to see how simple
they are then we're gonna move on to
part three which is where we study
composition theorems so this is how you
extend price of energy bounds from
simple mechanisms like say a single item
option to a more complex one like a
bunch of single item options running in
parallel and then whatever time i have
left at the end i'll talk about a new
very powerful approach for proving lower
bounds on the price of anarchy which
leverages
computational communication complexity
and lieu of explicit constructions
all right so remember the sort of
extension theorem approach to proving uh
price of energy bounds for you know uh
general sets of equilibria so you start
you think about okay what do i want my
theorem to say what do i want my
guarantee to be about and at the moment
we're thinking about auctions so we're
thinking about games of incomplete
information we should be thinking about
bayes nash equilibria bayes national
equilibrium depend on the prior what's
the prior well who knows so we really
like bayes nash equilibria guarantees
for arbitrary prior distributions right
that's what we want our theorem to say
so we put that in the right box
and then we say well what would we be
much happier actually just establishing
actually being tasked with proving and
in this case we're going to use complete
information games so think as if you
instantiated everybody's private
valuations and made them common
knowledge and you just look at pure nash
equilibria and the goal of an extension
theorem is to take whatever bound you
prove in this very very special case and
extend that exact same approximation
bound to the much more general situation
you actually care about so we went
through this in detail and complete
information games yesterday i also
introduced the how to modify it to
handle games of incomplete information
but let me remind you how it goes
so i think for the moment just think
about like a first price auction single
item first price auction so you fix the
setting and remember we want to we
really want to do our analysis in a
complete information setting so we
actually fix the valuations okay so it's
sort of sort of weird but it's just for
the analysis only it's like a first
price auction with commonly known
valuations
now the rest proceeds as it did before
you choose some baseline strategies okay
so i was calling these s star mostly
yesterday now the b stark is their bids
these should correspond to some optimal
outcome and then it should be the case
that uniformly across all of their
outcomes i.e all other bid profiles b
there's some disentangling inequality
which holds okay and so we had one last
time and this is the one we're using
right now so it just says if you look at
this entangled version of the bid
profiles b and b star you look at the
utilities earned by the deviators right
after a deviator deviates to its
baseline strategy you should be able to
lower down the sum of the deviator's
utilities by a suitable linear
combination of the two things we
actually care about actually there's a
little bit of a tweak so you might have
expected welfare here from yesterday by
any reason by analogy but it's a good
optimization to write revenue instead
okay so we take this number that we
don't care about and relate it to two
numbers that we do care about uh mu is
just set to one lambda is going to be
less than one the closer this is to one
the better the stronger the guarantee
okay
and then what's going to be true is that
whenever you prove an inequality like
this about your game so this is the step
where you have to understand your game
okay the parameter lambda will be
different for different games okay and
if your game is special maybe you have a
nice lambda close to one what's
independent of the game is going to be
the extension theorem okay so whatever
your game is whatever your lambda is if
you prove a guarantee through this
inequality you will automatically get a
guarantee of lambda on the bayes nash
price of anarchy for a worst-case prior
distribution okay so that's the paradigm
so you first understand special you know
you establish this for a fixed game then
you use the machinery to extend it
now again for a definition to be
interesting
you should demand examples you should
demand implications and i went through
this very quickly last time but i want
to show you the actual the proofs so
there's many examples but i'm going to
focus on the example of a first price
auction and i'm going to prove to you
this inequality with a lambda of
one-half and then i'm actually going to
prove to you the extension theorem okay
so last time we saw an extension theorem
for no regret sequences here we're going
to see an extension theorem for bayes
nash equilibria all right
all right so i just rewrote that
smoothness inequality again okay so the
claim is that the smoothness inequality
holds for a first price auction with
lambda equal to one-half
if you could go backwards
when you choose the baseline b star
uh
can it be like arbitrary or does like
each person's b star depend only on his
valuation or something like that
excellent question at the moment i'm
being intentionally um
sort of non-committal about it okay so
at the moment just you choose b star
okay and i'll show you in the first
price auction i'll show you exactly how
i said b star so i think the right thing
to do is
basically next slide b star is just
going to be bit half your value
okay so that'll be b that'll be b star
right so so let me prove to you for a
first price auction that satisfies that
inequality now remember the order of
quantifiers gets a little tricky here
okay so let's keep them in mind no
matter so we fix an arbitrary valuation
profile okay so for every v
there should exist baseline strategies b
star so that for every other bid profile
b
this inequality holds okay for every
valuations v there exists p star so that
for every b this is true okay
so but this is the whole proof the proof
is like trivial okay so this is like the
one time where we actually think about a
first price auction everything else is
just kind of black box and all we have
to think about with the first person
auction is the following totally trivial
argument okay
so why is this true okay so obviously
the issue is like okay what are the b
stars okay b star is very simple okay so
you fix your arbitrary valuations v1
through vn
we're just going to set the baseline
strategy for bitter i to be to bid half
your value
okay so vi over two that's it those are
the b stars okay so there's a really
nice trick actually you're not i'm not
going to be able to really show you this
again in the talk but this bit hatchery
value is a really nice trick it shows up
all the time over the past few years
okay
so what so think about a first price
auction so notice each term on the
left-hand side so this is the utility
earned by some bidder i after it bids
half its value okay two things can
happen in a first price auction if you
bid half your value you could lose
utility zero
you could win
utility
half your value right because you pay
your bid only two things that could
happen
so you never get non-negative utility
it's either zero or half your value so
this is not negative so this is trivial
unless the right hand side is positive
yeah otherwise there's nothing to prove
because the left-hand side is definitely
non-negative
so assume that in fact you know half the
opt welfare is strictly bigger than the
revenue of this arbitrary bid profile b
okay
so it's a single item option so what is
opt welfare opt welfare is just the
biggest valuation okay let's call it
bitter number one okay
this is the one part i'll use the first
price option and not say a second price
auction what's the revenue on a given
bid profile b it's just the highest bid
okay because that's who wins and you
charge the bid all right so saying that
the right hand side is strictly positive
is the same as saying that half of the
highest value
is at least the highest bid in this bid
vector b okay
okay well under this assumption let's
think about the high value bidder say
bitter number one
what happens to bitter one
when everybody else bids according to b
and
bitter one bids half its value
well it wins
right so under our assumption half of
the highest value is bigger than all of
the bids in b
so in the very first term in this sum
when bidder won the high value bitter
bits half its value it wins therefore it
gets value v over two okay
which is also at least the right hand
side
okay
there's even at least three inside
without the minus revenue term so that's
it you know it's kind of it's maybe it's
you know it's a clever setup of the case
analysis but it's literally two lines we
will never need to think about the
details of first price auctions ever
again in the rest of the talk okay even
to handle simultaneous compositions and
so on
okay so i mentioned this last time but
it you can be a little bit more clever
than just bidding half your value you
can be at a distribution over uh
possible bids and you can improve this
50 to 63 okay so i'm not going to show
you that now that i've told you that
you're all totally capable of working
out as a homework problem can be done
okay so you can do 63 if you want
questions
um
i
i'm trying to think of a
non-silly answer to that question so i
mean what would be uh people obviously
care about making these numbers bigger
yes
bigger is better has anything else to
say i mean or a bit differently one
possible
motivation
reason people use auctions is because
the price they're bound is quote good
unquote
does it matter if it is 63 if it had
been a quarter would that have been good
enough good so
things that if one wanted to convince an
economic silence
this discussion is important but it
doesn't happen here sure no now i
understand what you're asking so
i'd say there's two different things to
distinguish one would be are you trying
to make a comparison between two
different auctions and what are you
trying to just analyze a single auction
now your question i think is more
important to the former question which
is you know if you have one auction with
a you know worst case price of energy of
0.5 the other is 0.6 you know how
confidently can you say you should use
the 0.6 auction
i mean i think it's not you'd have to do
some experimentation to have confidence
in that i think what you know what the
approximation lens tends to be good for
is drawing coarser distinctions and
we'll see an example later today where
you know there'll be one setting where
you get reasonable constant factor
approximations and then there are other
settings where you get literally nothing
you can just have arbitrarily bad
welfare so it's almost like a zero
versus non-zero comparison
that i think is relevant for comparing
auctions just even sort of straight out
of the box
now here as far as this optimization i
just want to point out you know we've
i've i've just fixed the math question
right there's actually there's nothing
right so really just as as analysts it's
our responsibility to prove whatever the
truth is and so i claim that you know
going from 50 to 63 with a fixed auction
format is just you know something you'd
want to know you just want to know a
typed bound for a given auction format
is that there's a bound that's not zero
then if you prove zero one we could
declare victory and go home and say yes
we can improve it but we don't care
yeah i mean
i would like the strongest true
statement possible maybe it's just an
aesthetic thing but uh
that's i would argue that you know i
would really like to know for
a
fundamental auction format like a first
price auction i actually want to just
you know know the truth of what the
right answer is mathematically i get the
interpretation question is very
important but i think that comes in more
when you're like okay if you start
thinking about making a decision how
does this inform our decision making i
think it's an excellent question and so
there i think it's only the course or
comparisons that are that are relevant
somebody will optimize so it might as
well be me you know so
so i guess i guess
one point to say they're about say one
percent versus 50 versus 63 is let's
suppose it would take you 100 pages of
proof to go from a one percent proof
which was maybe two lines like you just
did to a 50
which is then 100 pages
then is it important for a theorist like
yourself to spend that amount of time
writing this energy proof down
and i think you'd probably say no
like you wouldn't bother to do that yeah
there's some cost-benefit analysis about
how much better the theorem gets versus
the opportunity cost where you could
have been proving more interesting
theorems i agree
in this case
yeah exactly in this case bacillus's
trick is very simple so it's absolutely
worth going from the 50 to 60 63
exactly
okay
we're gonna move on so yeah
i think the issue is somewhat different
the price of anarchy is telling you
what's the worst amount you could lose
as compared to doing the best possible
and the tighter band you can get on that
it seems to be the better it is
i don't so
of course the stronger sperm implies the
weaker theorem
but with christians what's the theorem
good for us help us think about this
this institution
and
so
one answer seems to be
what matters for that question is
whether it's
zero or not and it's just a stronger
math result than different numbers or a
different view as it actually matters
you know for some
um normative or predictive question what
the number is and i was trying to i was
agnostic that was the case i was trying
to have some discussion about about
what let's think about the numbers oh of
course
smaller theorets are stronger than we
predicted
i'm not thinking this is a theorem at
all i mean of course it is a theorem but
i i'm not
putting a better number just to get a
better theorem
so one of the one of the one other thing
i'll say and then i'd like to move on
would be if you really nail the um if
you get if you have a tight analysis it
almost always as a byproduct gives you
an understanding of what the worst case
examples look like
so you know in particular here you can
ask okay if 63 is the best possible what
matches that and then you often look at
those instances and you see you can and
then one of two things happens either
you see features that are actually
relevant to the real world to the
non-pathological instances and then
you're like oh okay this tells you give
me some advice about when this auction
format state will perform close to this
worst case actually more common you're
like oh those are the bad examples those
are stupid and then you go back and you
say okay what do i mean stupid so what
do i mean by a real instance and you
sort of sharpen your definition of which
instances you care about and then
hopefully you can prove better
approximation bounds so you can also
regard it as kind of the opening foray
of a back and forth between kind of the
instances you care about and the worst
case approximations you want to prove
so
all right so let me move on to the
extension theorem all right so we now
have an example so you really can't
establish this inequality at least for
first price auctions like i said there's
many other examples i won't have time to
talk about them why should you care you
should care because you automatically
get bayes nash price of anarchy bounds
for work for worst case uh
prior distributions
all right so
assume we've proved this this is what we
just proved for the first price auction
would land equal to half
let me warm up with a totally
uninteresting statement okay which is
just to say at least the pure price of
anarchy
is gamma or better lambda or better
excuse me okay
so suppose this is true i claim that you
know if there's a pure nash equilibrium
it has at least a lambda fraction of the
optimal welfare
so pick your favorite pure nash
equilibrium okay b
this is what we want to lower bound you
want to say that welfare is high okay
so the welfare splits into just the
revenue to the seller plus the sum of
the player utilities just by definition
so now we invoke the nash equilibrium
hypothesis if any bidder switches to any
other bid holding everyone else fixed
its utility only drops in particular if
it switches to a baseline strategy b
star i the utility only goes down
by our assumption we can disentangle
that entangled term and charge it
against lambda times the optimal welfare
minus the revenue of the bid vector b
the two revenue terms cancel and we're
just left with lambda times the optimal
welfare okay so it's almost immediate
okay so pure nash equilibria fine okay
but that was sort of the point remember
remember the extension theorem mindset
you prove something easy like this then
you just apply a black box to extend it
to bayes nash equilibria
actually here the extension theorem is
just as easy as this argument okay so
how do you change this so that it
applies to bayes nash equilibria
well so there's going to be some prior
but fix an arbitrary prior this is going
to turn into a bayes nash equilibrium so
remember what that means instead of bids
these will be bidding functions mapping
values to bids
and then in here we'll just take
expectation
over this arbitrary prior of the
valuations
okay boom
so this is what you get all right so
it's the exact same hypothesis haven't
changed the hypothesis
much stronger statement arbitrary prior
distribution bayes nash price of anarchy
lambda or better there's a bayes nash
equilibrium the parentheses just reminds
us a bidding function not a bid and then
i just added expectations over the over
the distribution throughout okay so we
average over the valuations we look at
the bids that
are used when those evaluation profiles
and so on and so forth okay exact same
computation okay
so there's a subtle point which was
asked about earlier but i'll get back to
that a little bit all right but so
that's your that's your that's your
extension theorem if you establish this
inequality you actually get a lambda for
bayes nash equilibria even for
correlated valuation distributions
all right so i wanted to next move on to
composition theorems there any questions
before i do that
regret minimization
play out in
good days
yeah so there's a there's a new paper
actually by jason and bacillus and eva
that handles this so they're the ones to
ask about that so there are basically
you can as my understanding is you can
combine you have both so you can have
sort of easily learned and complete
information
bounds that basically obey the same kind
of guarantees
but i asked ask ava vasilis and jason
for more
other questions
so last stuff i can't talk about uh more
applications of this specific smoothness
guarantee
different versions of the smoothness for
critical bid or second price type rules
um some interesting interpretations in
terms of revenue covering which actually
allows you to estimate empirically the
price of anarchy in real auctions from
data i think is very cool
um even extensions of this to dynamic
environments where you have bitters
churning because there's been a lot
going on that i don't have time to talk
about
instead i want to again really what you
know my foremost goal here is to just
show you the toolbox okay to convince
you that actually you can build up
really general statements from just a
lot of really simple to assemble pieces
so this next thing is going to be one of
those uh you know tools which is
reducing complex mechanisms to simple
ones
so i've only talked about single item
auctions so far suppose you had many
items different items okay
now when you only have one item it's
very easy to understand you know what a
bidder wants there's just the single
dimensional valuation what's it's
willing to pay for the one item
you start scaling the number of items m
and bitters can start having very
complex preferences right so in
principle a bitter could have a
different value for each of the two to
the m subsets of items it could get okay
so the valuation is blowing up
exponentially
in the number of items now one thing
that makes commentarial auctions these
multi-item auctions such a sort of
productive theoretical playground is you
can get lots of different types of
problems welfare maximization problems
by varying the allowable valuations okay
so you can draw diagrams like this
there's many other sets i haven't
written so you could have general
evaluations where any bidder could have
any value for any subset maybe monotone
say or you can impose restrictions which
of course only makes the problem easier
should only make your approximation
guarantees better okay so submodular
this is what i mentioned on the very
first representative result yesterday
for now i'm going to just for the talk
i'm going to focus on unit demand
valuations although all the results from
this part are more general okay the
results from this part hold basically
somewhere between these third and fourth
bubbles okay so more general than
submodular
what's a unit demand valuation that
means each bidder only wants one thing
okay so it can have preferences among
the different things right so it's a
bitter i have vijs for each item j but
if you give me lots of items i basically
just throw out all of the ones except
the one i like the most okay so formally
your value for a bundle is just the
maximum of your item values okay so
that's a unit demand valuation
now
you know if you wanted with unit demand
valuations you could just run the vcg
mechanism and it would be fine it's just
a bipartite matching problem okay but
suppose actually you want to do
something even simpler than bipartite
matching suppose you wanted to sell
these m items separately in parallel
simultaneously using single item
auctions let's say first price auctions
okay
what would happen there's obviously
something you could do right you could
again just put a bunch of goods up for
sale on ebay something like that see
what happens
would this work well let's say with
bidders have unit demand valuations and
not obvious our priority i claim at all
whether this would have any kind of
interesting guarantee or not
actually i want you to so
just think about composing first price
auctions although the you know you can
define this generally you have a bunch
of mechanisms you can think about the
simultaneous composition this just means
you play them all in parallel okay so
you choose a bid for each of the
constituent mechanisms what you win at
the end is the union of what you win
from the constituent mechanisms what you
pay is the sum of your payments from the
constituent mechanisms okay don't forget
that
so
as a result say you're a unit demand
bidder okay and suppose you have the
same value for every item okay there are
these 20 options
you want to win one of them and you get
value one okay if you win one item you
still have value only one if you win two
okay so you don't want more than one
what kind of bit so you get to submit 20
bids okay a bid in each of these
auctions
what should you do
and notice it's kind of not it's not an
easy question right so one thing you
could do is you could go all in you know
on like item 17 you know you could bid
like you know 0.9 on item 17 to make
sure that you have a really good chance
of winning it or you could be a bargain
hunter and bid like 0.1 on a whole bunch
of them hoping that one of them has like
basically no competition can you get
something at a bargain but the worry is
that you know if you try to bid in more
than one you'll win more than one you
pay for both or all of them but you only
get value from one okay so it's really
not obvious what you should do as a unit
demand bitter and simultaneous first
price auctions say okay and so
equilibrium are not that easy to
understand but as we've seen we'll still
be able to prove theorems about the
equilibria even though we don't really
understand them
okay
so here's the composition theorem uh i
want to tell you about
which says suppose your constituents
mechanisms are lambda smooth in the
sense we've been discussing so first
price auction is one half smooth
then
with unit demand valuations smoothness
is preserved under composition
okay so take any lambda smooth singleton
options run any number of them that you
want in parallel that is with unit
demand valuations then this parallel
composition is again lambda smooth with
exactly the same lambda okay
so composition preserves smoothness
right or if you like
this reduces having to prove anything
about the
composed mechanism to merely proving
something about one of the single item
auctions which we did on three lines
it's pretty cool okay
so that's the theorem okay and again
it's i'm sticking with unit demand for
simplicity but it holds more generally
okay for so this is still true for
submodular evaluations it's even true
for so-called xos valuations for those
of you that know what that means okay
but let's just stick with unit demand
for simplicity
so the proof is actually very elegant
i'm not going to do it in detail but
i'll tell you the key idea because
actually the idea is going to be
important for a subtlety later
remember what it means to prove that
something's smooth okay again there's
all these quantifiers so it's easy to
get confused what do you have to prove
you have to prove that no matter what
the evaluation profile is
you can choose baseline strategies that
this inequality holds for all bid
profiles b so the hypothesis is that the
single item auction is smooth okay so in
a single item option everything's single
dimensional so that would say for every
value for every profile of one
dimensional evaluations there's uh
there's baseline strategies which are
one-dimensional bids so that for every
one dimensional bit vector b this holds
what do we have to prove we have to
prove the analogous inequality for the
composed mechanism where there's m
single item options
so now we have to prove that for every
valuation profile where now evaluation
is m-dimensional where m is the number
of items for every m-dimensional
valuation profile we can choose baseline
strategies again each of those is going
to be an m-dimensional bid vector so
that for every bid strategy every bid
profile b again m-dimensional this
inequality holds right so that's what we
have to prove all right
so how do you do that
well
we're going to solve the problem in
effect this is only an analysis we're
not like you know actually modeling
behavior or sort of telling people what
to do but for the analysis
we basically think of solving this
problem of how should a unit demand
bitter bid okay in in these auctions
which is you should go all in or not
quite all in but you should bid half
your value on some item okay and zero on
everything else that's what the baseline
strategies are going to be
so the question then is you know bitter
17 which of the various items is its
baseline strategy going to be to go all
in in
and the trick here is you say well look
at what happens in the optimal solution
again keep in mind it's easy to get
confused this is all just in the
analysis oh we're just doing a proof of
an approximation guarantee for
equilibrium we're going to use the
language of algorithms okay and the
proof
so there's some optimal matching okay
the unit demand bitters okay so the
optimal solutions are matching each
bidder gets one or zero goods okay if
bitter i gets good j in the optimal
solution then its baseline strategy is
to bid half its value on good j and zero
everywhere else
okay
so that's the definition of the b stars
okay you fixed the valuation profile
what's the b star look at opt each bit
or bids half its value on whatever item
it gets an opt remember op depends on
the values right you can't talk about
welfare without fixing the values all
right when you fix the values then you
choose these baseline strategies half
your half your value on the good you get
an opt and that's it okay and basically
everything relevant is additive okay so
you literally just add up the single
item inequalities you get the desired
inequality
for the compose mechanism okay i'm going
to admit it but it's really it kind of
writes itself once you have it set up
properly okay it's very nice and again
it works more generally than unit demand
okay so any questions about that
so again this is the key point okay
simultaneous composition preserves
smoothness yeah
so i mean kind of relates what i took
earlier and maybe you should maybe
should wait because the whole next five
minutes is about that issue actually
yeah thanks so you're very on top of it
so it would seem
that we've proven the following theorem
assembling all of the different parts of
our toolbox together okay so what did we
do well we started with a first price
auction we had a two-line argument that
said it's smooth with parameter lambda
okay we just proved this composition
theorem so this says that simultaneous
first price auctions are also smooth
with parameter one-half okay
then we have our extension theorem which
says oh well if you're smooth with
parameter one-half that means the base
that base that for every prior
distribution even correlated
distributions the bayes nash price of
energy is within a factor two okay or a
factor one half right it seems like this
is what's true based on everything i've
told you okay again you the one the one
thing you have to do from scratch is the
first price auction then you do the
composition theorem then you do the
extension theorem
so why does it say first try
well there's actually there's there's if
you i don't expect you to remember but
on the very first slide yesterday
when i stated a representative result it
was actually not as strong as what's on
this slide okay there was there was sort
of a
it was a less general result that i
started out with and the reason is this
is actually false okay this statement
here everything i told you about first
price auctions was true okay so the
guarantee for worst case correlated
valuation distributions for first price
auctions that was correct but we're
missing something subtle in the
extension to multiple items okay so
there's actually a counter example
which says there are
distributions over unit demand
valuations there's super correlated
valuation distributions but there are
valuation distributions over unit
demands
so that every bayes nash equilibrium is
terrible okay arbitrarily far from
optimal all right
so it's definitely not a factor one-half
for a worst-case correlated uh prior
distribution okay
so
two pieces of good news
the first piece of good news is that a
slightly weaker statement is true and
the second piece of good news is that
the reason it's true is the sort of same
as the reasoning that i've already been
explaining to you
so what's going to be true is that for
every product distribution of
evaluations that is assuming the
valuations are drawn independently not
necessarily identically but it has to be
independent and the counter example
shows this is necessary
as long as the valuations are drawn from
independently from unit demand
distributions then no matter what those
distributions are no matter what base
national equilibrium you look at that's
when you get this guarantee of 50 or 63
if you like okay
why is this true well the first two
steps are exactly what i said okay
they're exactly what i've taught you
with no modification you analyze a
single item auction just in the full
information case in isolation you prove
that one half
the composition theorem was just correct
the way i stated it okay so it's just
true that simultaneous first price
auctions are also smooth the parameter
one half
the bug was in the extension theorem
okay and how i applied it and it was
exactly uh you're not as questioned was
getting at the issue okay it's a subtle
issue but it's important so that's what
i'm going to drill down on next okay so
i want to explain so we're going to need
to modify the extension theorem so i'm
going to do next is i'm going to show
you why the previous one isn't valid why
it is valid for first price auctions but
not valid for simultaneous first price
auctions how this gets modified and why
that relaxes the get the the sort of the
conclusion from arbitrary to product
distributions okay yep
um
for the single item case it's also kind
of giving you a prescription bidding a
half is a good idea but computationally
this isn't
how would you even
figure out what you should do so it's a
little i mean even you know it's a
little tricky that interpretation
i'm has i'm hesitant to interpret the
bit half your value as that prescriptive
it's sort of prescriptive if you want
like the aggregate welfare to be good
right so if you kind of want to do your
part to everybody enjoying a high
welfare guarantee then it is it is
prescriptive in an individual sense i'm
not so comfortable interpreting as
prescriptive
you're right that i mean what's
interesting about it is
uh you know when you do
a byproduct of this of all the
smoothness machinery is you know in
addition to all of the flavors of
equilibrium we've been discussing so far
these bounds hold more generally for
like any outcome in which every player
is doing at least as well as its
baseline strategy
right so which is much weaker than
equilibrium equilibrium says you're
doing better than every other strategy
uh so no but there'll be a fix where you
can in the first price auction you could
right and i'll show you a fix where you
can actually do that here too but it's
exactly the same bug that i'm talking
about that you're getting at okay
all right so again
uh i need to show you a different
extension theorem but of course i want
to explain to you what went wrong with
the previous one okay where's the
subtlety so for this i need to
distinguish between what i'm going to
call private and public baseline
strategies remember the order of
quantifiers in the smoothness bounds for
every valuation profile v you can choose
baseline strategies b star so that for
every bit vector b something is true
okay
so the rub is always how do you choose
these b stars now in the first price
auction how did we do it we just said
bid half your value okay bitter i okay
this is a private baseline strategy in
the sense that player i only needs to
know its own valuation vi
to execute this baseline strategy it
does not need to know v minus i okay in
other words b star is independent of v
minus i okay so that's what i'm calling
a private baseline strategy
on the other hand if you think about
that paradigm fixed v choose b star for
all b
in that paradigm you're free to choose b
star as a function of the full valuation
profile v
and actually in simultaneous first price
auctions that's exactly what we did
what were our baseline strategies fix
the valuation profile bid half of your
value on the good you get in opt
what is opt opt is the max welfare
solution of bipartite matching okay you
do not know what opt is unless you know
the full valuation profile okay if you
only know your valuation vi you have no
idea what opt is okay so the baseline
strategy i gave you in the composition
theorem is not private baseline okay
that is not well defined unless the
agent is aware of the full valuation
profile v okay it's a function of e
minus i also
okay
so is the distinction clear
so moving forward it's going to be that
private baseline strategies give you
bayes
guarantees for arbitrary correlated
distributions public baseline strategies
will give you guarantees only for
product distributions again that's how
it's going to play out
so in the single lighting auction you
didn't care about private versus
i didn't i didn't make these definitions
at that point
well i mean you always would prefer
private baseline strategies and it just
so happened the first price auctions you
could get them
okay
for first price but i think your
extension was general for like uh
any auction that's smooth so that's
where i'm going next right so let's look
at the extension theorem again that's
exactly what i want to show you okay
this is just a definition okay and it is
clear that you know somehow this is only
harder to do than this right so this is
the smaller design space you're working
in to choose the b stars
but but casa is asking exactly the right
question which is like well why didn't
that like trivial proof with all the
expectations why didn't they just go
through even with you know just these
public baselines so i want to show you
that that's important
especially because i sort of glossed
over this proof okay so what happens
when you prove these extension theorems
at some point you have to invoke the
equilibrium hypothesis okay you
basically say look if the player
switched to its baseline it would only
get worse okay
now in an incomplete information game
when a player contemplates what else it
might do
what does it know okay
it knew the prior distribution from the
beginning okay and it's x interim it's
learned its own valuation
but in a game of incomplete information
like an auction at the time a player
acts
it does not know v minus i okay and
there's a distribution over v minus i
and it knows the bidding strategies used
by those players it does not know v
minus i okay
so it would not make sense to say in
this derivation it would not make so it
only makes sense to say
um player i switches to its baseline
strategy if the baseline strategy is
private because it only knows vi it is
not well defined to say switch to your
public baseline strategy and invoke the
equilibrium condition okay it doesn't
make sense mathematically
okay
so that's where it breaks okay
on the other hand i hope you see if it
is a private baseline strategy if it
depends only on vi this proof is correct
okay just because this is well defined
okay you can really talk about switching
to your private baseline strategy in the
interim stage all right
okay great so this is kind of the most
subtle thing i have to say over these
these couple of days
all right so again to summarize the old
extension theorem it works it's very
power you know it's exactly what you
want arbitrary quality distributions it
works whenever you have private baseline
strategies and first price auctions you
do indeed have private baseline
strategies okay so you definitely do get
correlated uh price of energy bounds for
the single item case
right so this is the new this is the
really properly phrased extension
theorem for the correlated case
now what about simultaneous first price
auctions where we have these public
baseline strategies that depend on the
full evaluation profile okay
so now we need a new extension theorem
right the old one we know is broken we
have a counter example so the old one
just cannot be extended so we need to
strengthen the hypoth so you know we're
weakening the condition and that now the
baseline strategies are public not
private
we're going to get a weaker conclusion
uh which is that the guarantee will hold
only for product valuation distributions
and this theorem you now have to reprove
from scratch okay so this is this is
really a distinct result from anything
i've showed you so far in these talks
but it can be proved
let me just tell you kind of like the
idea from 30 000 feet okay so what went
wrong in the previous extension theorem
well we want to say in this line we want
to say well you know why doesn't the
players switch to its baseline strategy
okay and if it and if it's private
that's fine you can just think about it
switching to its private baseline
strategy if it's public the reason we
can't do this is because the bitter eye
does not know other people's valuations
does not know v minus i its public
baseline strategy is not well defined
on the other hand
bitter i does know it's always known a
distribution
from which v minus i is drawn it doesn't
know the realization and there's the
realization of its own type it doesn't
know the realization of v minus i but it
has a distribution
so if you have a distribution and you
need a realization
what should you do
you take a sample okay and this was a
really nice idea of christutaloo kovacs
and shapira
so what you do is and so again it
doesn't make sense to say think about
the players switching to its public
baseline strategy so instead you think
about a randomized deviation you think
about the player sampling fictitious
valuations for the rest of the players
call them w minus i
and then now that it knows its own
valuation and it has hypothesized
fictitious valuations for everyone else
now the public baseline strategy is well
defined
and that gives it an action that it can
take
okay and it's not at all obvious but
this works okay so this is what you do
in the
part of the proof where you invoke the
equilibrium condition you sample types
for everybody else that gives you a
well-defined baseline strategy and then
you reason about the player's utility if
it followed that randomized strategy
yeah so
cool
it's not at all clear i mean we we sort
of know it because there's a counter
example
and we so we know it has to come into
the proof
nothing i've said verbally indicates
where it shows up in the proof and
frankly it's tricky okay this is this
proof i think is actually pretty tricky
all right it's not that long but it's
it's uh
it's uh i think it's i think it's a
really nice tricky proof
good
okay
so
this puts it all together so this bit so
what the representative result that i uh
you know gave out at the beginning of
the first talk was now basically
something we've proved okay so yeah i
only gave you the derivation the 50 i
didn't give you the optimize 63
but you know again that's a that's a you
know a good homework problem uh i only
proved it for unit demand valuations
where i stated for some modular
evaluations at the beginning but that's
really just you know one extra lemma
okay short lemma okay so really
basically seeing that entire proof all
right and again what i think is so
amazing like if you look at the game
specific work that had to be done it was
a couple lines okay it was that one half
of the first price auction everything
else is black box applications of
composition and extension theorems
so for the composition theorem
you mentioned the unit demand version
yeah
is this what we should keep doing so
like uh what changes sure
yeah
let me quickly say how it works
um
so we just need to define baseline we
have to define baseline strategies right
so obviously if you're not unit demand
you can again say think about what i get
an opt but if you're not unit demand you
may get more than one thing okay so you
do the natural thing which is you go all
in in some sense on what on the goods
you get in opt
and zero and everything else
now what do you bid on the goods you get
knocked you kind of want to say like
half your value for each
and if you had like an added evaluation
that would make perfect sense the
problem is if you have like a general
submodular evaluation it's not you know
what is your sort of you get these three
goods how do you ascribe to each of them
your value just for that good
within this bundle
so there you use this trick that every
submodular function can be represented
as a maximum over additive functions
it turns out so basically you just sort
of look at all uh ways to order the
goods and you look at marginal values
you take the maximum algorithm and that
that expresses the valuation as the
point wise maximum of additive functions
and so then you look at so then again
there's all in the proof only okay so
you look at the goods you get in opt you
look at a supporting added evaluation
that gives you a number for each of the
goods and you get half of that number on
each of those goods
breaks down xos
so there's a result
there's a result for sub-additive which
i'll mention
yeah or fractions about evaluations
there's a result for sub-additive which
is direct and bypasses all this
machinery which i'll mention it i'll
talk about it yeah
yeah so i know there's a reason so that
paper we can't guess the same results by
lp duality yes
so that's something to say about it uh
right uh it's an open question the
extent to which is related i think it's
a really cool paper um this is uh
uh i'm trying to remember the authors so
i um isn't
the thing i really like about this paper
is they really show i mean there's some
other results recently that have also
been okay there's a couple papers
recently that have basically harnessed
the technology of approximation
algorithms which of course at this point
is very very very mature and showed how
to
basically translate approximation
algorithm guarantees in the price of
anarchy guarantees so there's this paper
in soda and then there's another paper
by
dud and kesselheim and tartosh and ec
for lp rounding papers the soda paper is
more kind of primal dual algorithms
and it sure looks like there should be
some connections
maybe not that strong but at least weak
connections to all this smoothness
notions but i don't know what they are
and i've talked to those authors about
them and we all agree it's an intriguing
open question so i encourage you to work
on it yeah now i'd love to know i'd love
to know what's going on i really don't
know what's going on with that
thanks for the question
other questions
okay
so
from uh for the last part i want to talk
a little bit about lower bounds okay so
as an analyst how do you know when
you're done how do you know when you
have an optimal bound or as a designer
how do you know you should give up
looking for better mechanisms versus
when should you try to find smarter
formats
so
let me motivate this discussion by so
constance was just alluding to this
result so let me tell you one example
there's lots of examples where we know
tight bounds on the price of anarchy but
let me mention one which is going to be
good for my narrative
we're going to stick with simultaneous
first price auctions when i write s1a i
mean simultaneous first price auctions
but i'm going to look at more general
valuation classes than we were in the
previous part okay so we were looking at
unit demand i mentioned it extended to
submodular
and uh let's actually just for fun think
about sub-additive valuations okay so
basically the sum of your value for two
different bundles is at least your value
for the union of those two bundles okay
this is pretty much the most general
notion of complement free valuations you
might work with okay so it certainly
doesn't capture everything it doesn't it
sort of excludes compliments but subject
to excluding compliments it's about as
general as it gets
we know exactly what the worst case
price of anarchy of simultaneous first
price options are with sabbat with
savannah to bitter valuations it's
exactly
two
okay
and there's one paper that is the upper
bound there's one paper that has the
lower bound both of these papers are
really really cool okay so the upper
bounds and feldman full grab and lucia
what's one thing that's really cool
about the upper bound is it was known
that smooth this is one of those rare
cases where smoothness is not a sharper
not sharp enough tool to prove the
optimal bound okay so smoothness gets
stuck uh logarithmic in the number of
items okay that's an old result of
chipper walker and i
so and you basically can't do better
than log m using the standard smoothness
type arguments so feldman and all devise
a way to in effect choose what i've been
calling baseline strategies but they
prove them specifically and separately
for each of the bayes nash equilibria
okay and that was verboten and
everything i was saying remember you
choose b star then something has to be
true for all b so they reverse those
quantifiers so for each equilibrium b
they figure out the right b star and
they can still push uh everything
through okay so that's the upper bound
which is very cool uh the lower bound by
christina lukovak's skriza and tang
is just really impressive okay because
these are complex games and they devise
um you know i'm just going to put a
figure here of some of the gadgets in
their ingenious construction so they
really exhibit distributions over
sub-added valuations and solve for a bad
equilibrium and so you can really be off
by a factor of two okay so this is also
just sort of a tour de force
and you know historically this is how
price of energy lower bounds have been
proved okay you just like write down the
game
write down the bad equilibrium in the
game okay and usually this is hard
explicit constructions okay and but it
has been done successfully in a number
of cases
this question so in the equilibrium do
we assume that the bidders must provide
a bid consistent with the class
evaluations you're assuming
uh it's not even totally clear what that
means given the sort of massive
compression on the message space right i
mean you basically i'm basically forcing
you to bid an added evaluation
in a simultaneous first price auction
right so i can rationalize any bid
vector if you like that's one way to
think about it for all i know you have
an added evaluation yeah
okay so so here's a here's a so lower
bounds historically have been proven by
explicit constructions which are
difficult and so what i want to advocate
in this last part is instead standing on
the shoulders of complexity theory which
has a very rich lower bound technique
and from it deducing lower bounds
automatically on the price of anarchy
okay without having to do any kind of
explicit construction the other reason
this is going to be really interesting
is it'll actually allow us to make
optimality statements
for example
suppose you want a simple mechanism for
selling multiple items for bidders with
sub-added evaluations
can you do better than a factor of two
the lower bound shows you can't do
better than a factor of two with
simultaneous first price auctions to do
better you'd have to change the auction
format maybe but maybe you can be
smarter have a lower price of anarchy so
we'll be able to actually say
mathematically you cannot
do better than a factor two no matter
what simple mechanism you use okay so in
this sense simultaneous first price
auctions for the worst case price of
energy criterion are optimal amongst all
simple mechanisms in a sense i'll define
precisely okay so that's why we're doing
this
all right
so
the goal of the main result of this
fourth part
is to say that equilibria
are generally bound by the same
limitations as computation efficient
algorithms okay
this is not an obvious statement because
equilibria are not algorithms okay
they're just mathematical objects okay
so it's not obvious that sort of the
laws of polynomial time computation you
know it's not clear to what extent those
those apply to them
but it's going to turn out that the
types of lower bounds that we typically
prove in computational communication
complexity are somehow strong enough
that equilibria even when not polynomial
time computable still can't dodge those
lower bounds so it's going to be a very
general result the the assumptions which
are important and necessary is it refers
to equilibrium concepts which are
guaranteed to exist because you want to
think about like mixed nash equilibria
and generalizations
and it should be the case that the
equilibrium is efficiently verifiable so
notice this the hypothesis is not that
the equilibrium is efficiently
computable that is not required
but if someone hands you an alleged
equilibrium on a silver platter you
should at least be able to recognize it
as such in polynomial time okay that's
also going to be important
all right
so here's the formal statement and this
is a mouthful uh
uh
yes
yes so the statements actually about
epsilon
the statements about epsilon equilibria
for
epsilon extremely small so yeah so the
real that's how i sort of dodged the
real number issue basically
yeah
that's uh that's a good point
okay so
i'm going to put this up there if you
don't know what some of these words mean
that's fine okay let me just tell you
how to interpret what this is saying
this so this is the formal statement but
let me just tell you what the takeaway
is the main takeaway is this last point
okay
you want to prove lower bounds on the
price of anarchy on equilibria so this
is a theorem which is going to say well
if you want lower bounds on equilibria
all you have to do is prove lower bounds
on an optimization problem okay on
something which has nothing to do with
game theory you just have to prove that
some copy optimization problem is hard
in a suitable computational model okay
so it absolves you from for example
having to solve any game for an
equilibrium and that's always a good
thing right like the whole price of
anarchy machinery you know on the upper
bound side the whole point was to be
able to reason about situations where
it's sort of incomprehensible to think
about solving for equilibria now we want
to do the same on the lower bound side
okay and so that's what this does okay
forget about the game just look at the
underlying optimization problem prove a
hardness result
okay so now again reading the slide from
bottom to front so what's the formal so
there's going to be some hardness
assumption don't worry about it too much
alpha is just the approximation hardness
and the assumption and then what you get
is that for every possible it's okay
sorry so let's fix some valuation class
like sub-additive evaluations okay and
suppose welfare maximization is hard for
subordinate evaluations for some factor
half for some factor alpha like a factor
two
the conclusion says
for every possible simple mechanism okay
and i'll say what that means in a second
but for every six possible simple
mechanism not just simultaneous first
price auctions literally anything else
you could do every possible simple
mechanism will suffer
from bad equilibria
how bad the lower bound alpha is the
same as the lower bound and the hardness
of approximation assumption okay so for
example if you can prove something like
you can't do better than a two
approximation for the optimization
problem you get that no simple mechanism
has a price of energy better than two
okay so it translates in a possibility
result for algorithms to an
impossibility result for equilibria of
mechanisms okay that's the point so what
do i mean by simple simple is just
counting the number of actions available
to every player okay so remember there's
you're not remember those m items okay
uh and so what would a direct revelation
mechanism be like vcg
well i have to get two to the m
numbers from each bitter okay so there's
two to the n parameters so if i want to
count actions that's like doubly
exponential in m
okay so for example i could be either
zero or 1 for each of the 2 to the m
bundles 2 to the 2 to the vm
so simple here just says
it's not direct revelation basically
okay it just says look with this with a
doubly exponential number of actions you
could run vcg
okay you'd be great you'd be full
welfare if you have anything less than a
doubly exponential number of actions
then the price of anarchy must suddenly
jump to whatever the approximation
hardness is for the underlying
optimization problem okay so that's what
simple means sub w exponential number of
actions per player simultaneous first
price auctions
right you only have m bidding parameters
so at least if we discretize the bids
there's a singly exponential number of
actions per player in a simultaneous
first price auction okay so this says i
give you massively more auction actions
than a simultaneous first price auction
i'll let you use them however you want
be as clever as you want still you
cannot escape this alpha factor from the
underlying hardness result
all right so
let me give you some interpretations
right so again this wouldn't be
interesting all right so it reduces
lower bounds for equilibrium lower
bounds for algorithms this wouldn't be
useful unless we had lower bounds for
algorithms okay but a huge like a huge
humidity has been working on lower
bounds for algorithms for a very long
time and we know a tremendous amount so
for example taking that theorem on the
last slide and combining it with known
lower bounds for algorithms due to
nissan cigar dabsdinsky nissan shapira
we can find the following okay so in the
class of allowable valuations is
sub-additive evaluations it's been known
about since about 10 years ago
that you can't approximate welfare
maximization efficiently better than a
factor two okay for sub-added
evaluations so alpha on the last slide
in the hypothesis was 2.
what does the theorem on the last side
then give us it says that every simple
auction again sub w w exponential number
of actions has to have a price of
anarchy of 2 or worse
okay
now recall we had this upper bound for
simultaneous first price auctions and
that upper bound was two
okay and that was you know a simple
auction exponential number of actions so
in this formal sense simultaneous first
price auctions are the optimal
simple mechanism for bidders with
sub-additive evaluations again where our
performance criterion is the worst case
price of anarchy there's no simple
option which is better than a factor two
if you look at general evaluations then
it's known that the welfare maximization
problem is totally intractable okay you
can't even get a one percent
approximation
so applying the theorem on the previous
slide says that every single simple
mechanism okay meaning basically not
direct revelation
uh has terrible welfare at the worst
case equilibrium
okay so in particular you know there's
been a lot of discussion in the comments
real auction world about you know do
control auctions have to be complex or
not so for example something a lot of
blood and ilk inc has been spilt over is
package bidding
okay
should you allow bidders to be able to
endogenously propose packages okay say i
want you know licenses 3 7 12 and 15 and
here's what i'm willing to pay for all
of them or should you disallow package
bidding or only allow very restricted
package bidding it's been a lot big
discussion about that
so an interpretation here and you know
one of the
one you know one school of thought says
well you know if you have severe
complementarities you have no option but
to have package bidding in complex
auction formats and this is a theorem
which really translates directly to that
rule of thumb right so if you have
general evaluations meaning you have
complements then what this says is
without an extremely large action space
it's totally hopeless to have good
welfare guarantees this is a formal way
of saying complexity is essential when
bidders have complementarity when items
have complementarities
good call
okay so questions about that
yep
yep
is this for general them or just for
options
yeah it's it's it's it's very general um
so there's some very mild assumptions
required but it's really not about
auctions
really what i mean so you can you i mean
so if you look at the paper it's phrased
pretty generally so basically you just
have a notion of a game
sorry you have a notion of an
optimization problem and then you have a
notion of a game built on top of an
optimization problem in the sense that
any game outcome gets mapped
to
some solution to an optimization problem
and so the general version of theorem
says whatever the hardness of the
underlying optimization problem is
that becomes a lower bound on a game
defined on that optimization problem
so for example you know i'm talking
about these simple auctions the
underlying optimization problem there is
welfare maximization okay the question
is just given valuations how close can
you get to the maximum possible welfare
any simple auction or any auction period
you can think of as a game built on top
of that optimization problem in the
sense that you know once bidders act and
some allocation is decided upon there is
some welfare okay so an outcome
particular equilibrium of the game gives
you
uh
a feasible solution optimization problem
and
you know if you and what this is saying
is if you know polynomial time
algorithms or polynomial communication
protocols can't do a good job at
optimizing welfare then in fact uh you
know simple mechanisms also at
equilibrium cannot do a good job of
optimizing welfare and again the reason
this isn't trivial is because equilibria
are not in general polynomial polynomial
time computable if they were then this
would be you know have no content okay
but in general they're more powerful
than algorithms yeah
so for the hypothesis of the theorem
how many parties
are in the communication models
um so that varies with the setting
um so for these i mean here it's
whatever right so this is agnostic this
theorem
uh for the nissan so nissan and seagal
they use
let me think
four
for this one
it's not you you can have large players
or small players and you get negative
results either way
um
here i forget if you need you may need
many players to get this to approach too
okay so it's gonna say to approach two
you need many
players consonant you get this not just
yeah if it's gonna be three halves or
something or yeah four thirds or
something yeah yeah so to get to two you
need the number of players to grow
thanks matt
okay and so you know so as far as the
takeaway here you know this stuff i
don't necessarily want you to care about
so i just want to remember this
okay the fact that there is a method
there are general theorems which take as
input lower bounds for algorithms and
give as output lower bounds for
equilibria
why is this cool there's two reasons
this is cool first of all it absolves
you from having to
figure out a bad game and solve for an
equilibrium in a bad game okay solving
for equilibrium especially in complex
games
anything you can do to avoid having to
solve for an equilibrium in a big game
just you want to do okay so this
absolves you from the explicit
construction but then also you know
we have these explicit constructions say
for simultaneous first price auctions
you know but if i tweak the auction
format you know all of a sudden you know
i have to from scratch potentially you
have to come up with a new bad
equilibrium maybe even a new game if i
vary the auction format a little bit so
i'd have to redo the explicit
construction format by format whereas
from
these hardness results you get sweeping
lower bounds that apply to linearly any
mechanism in this case any simple
mechanism with not too many actions okay
so those are the two reasons why i think
you might want to care about this
sometimes it's hard to find a nasty
program so but
sometimes in the poa is not good but
there is some approach to
to to approximate the proximal value
efficiently right so but the claim is
not an if and only if
if that's what you're asking i mean the
price of energy might be still worse
than the lower bound provided by these
kinds of theorems right
or was that not the question
so it's one direction only right so the
price of energy can't be any better
than the
inner probability result for the
optimization problem it could be worse
and there are plenty of examples where
it is worse
so the communication model here is like
a private best knife giving up it's like
uh
it can't complete the information
i i didn't hear you i'm sorry
right so so i mean it uh
you have uh basically bidders with
private valuations
and that's what i think about it i mean
it's the communication model that
exactly is the one you'd want to use
given that what you're trying to model
is bidders with private valuations who
don't know each other's valuations
other questions
but double auctions that would run
simultaneously and would just run until
they converge towards an equilibrium
would they count as simple mechanisms in
in your sense because you could resell
the stuff that you
bought on ebay on ebay if you uh
only have so so how do you want to model
it i mean so this this refers to
anything which where the no the action
space is not really really big
so
so it kind of so so this is really about
mechanisms where the type space is small
compared or you know somewhat small
compared to the to the type space
um so if you're referring to a mechanism
that also has that property then these
lower bound should still hold
yeah just like exchanges running in
parallel for each of the goods
yeah
yeah i mean
there's there's this delicate question
of exactly how you know what is the
action set and i can imagine different
ways of defining that and if you have
like an infinite horizon maybe you have
an infinite number of strategies and
then
it doesn't quite match up i suspect you
could still repair it by say oh well
after a small number of time steps you
have an approximate equilibrium and then
this still applies but at least
as stated it needs the you need some
kind of control on the number of actions
yes so is it important that the number
is it really about number of actions or
about the amount of communication that
happens in the mechanism
well so
so here's what's really going on what's
really going on is
through taking an action i think of an
action is basically communicating log
you know of the number of actions about
you right so if you have lots of actions
then a single action can communicate a
lot right so somehow in the reduction in
the proof of this theorem
that's the mapping that happens if you
look at something like a double auction
where it actually responds to what other
agents are doing
then
there i mean my strategy space is huge
but i don't actually signal all that
that's an excellent point right so that
would that would be that would be nice
so that would be this this proof is
uh
blunt to capture that kind of idea but i
think
it does seem like you one should be able
to do something like that and that would
be cool
so
yeah
okay
so wrapping up
okay so let me just wrap up i guess with
a few open questions uh so again the
whole point of these talks was to kind
of you know encourage you to prove more
theorems in the area and in particular
there's i think some really
user-friendly theorems which you can now
build on both the upper bound side and
lower bound side but there's all kinds
of fundamental stuff we don't know i
mentioned multiple times even for you
know single item first price auction
independent valuations we don't know
what the worst case welfare loss can be
at a base nash equilibrium it's a little
embarrassing okay we don't know the
answer we just know bounds
uh
one really intriguing concrete open
question
concerns simultaneous first price
auction or concerns sorry simple
auctions for bidders with submodular
valuations okay so my representative
result at the very beginning of
yesterday gave a bound of 63 percent
okay so we know that simultaneous first
price auctions get 63 percent
the same lower bound paper i mentioned
earlier chris tudulu would all show that
for the specific format of simultaneous
first price auctions this analysis is
tight okay so 63 is the correct answer
for the specific format of simultaneous
first price auctions
but of course you got to wonder
can we do better
maybe a different auction format will
get us closer to full efficiency we
don't know the answer to this question
okay and what we do know is that no
simple mechanism can get better than 77
percent okay this follows from the
theorem i just mentioned plus known
communication lower bounds
it's also known that the lower bound
framework that i presented to you today
will be incapable of proving that 63 is
optimal
and that's because if you just look at
communication protocols you can do just
ever so slightly better than 63 percent
okay so the upshot being is nailing the
optimal simple auction for submodular
evaluations would require either at
least one of the following two things a
novel auction format to get an upper
bound better than simultaneous first
price auctions and or a novel lower
bound uh framework that proves lower
bounds better than what's true for the
underlying optimization problem okay so
really love to see progress on that
problem
more generally you know i think now now
understanding that the lower bounds for
algorithms you know are going to govern
what any mechanism could achieve
that sort of draws a line on the sand
okay so it really says okay as we think
about you know different kinds of
auction formats if we want to not just
analyze existing formats but think about
you know how might we tweak them to make
them better you know in some sense if
you're the kind of person that likes you
know trying to optimize bounds and get
them as good as possible we now know
where we want to get to right we want to
get to the hardness result for the
underlying computational communication
problem
so
that's all for me thanks very much
jason
is it possible that your lower back
with
hard to see how because the underlying
optimization problem is not hard
so
do you have any idea of i mean so
the challenge of showing tighter lower
bounds for one
is you have to put your hands on
equilibrium in a setting where it's
really hard to put your hands on
equilibrium
i would say so at the moment we have
literally no general tools
for proving lower bounds stronger than
those apply
uh that what comes from the optimization
problem so any such tool of any type
would be very valuable
so pretty much at the moment if we want
to prove a lower bound in any setting
where the optimization problem is easy
we're back to the stone age where you've
got to do an explicit construction and
solve for a bad equilibrium obviously
it'd be great to have new methodology
there that w an awesome result
um does the reduction for lower bounds
for chris of anarchy work for price of
anarchy for auction revenue as well
um
let me think
so what's your
the did
where your
your what's so what's the optimization
problem you want to redefine the
optimization problem also as being
revenue maximization
uh it's a good question i never thought
about that um
yes
yes something similar would be true so
you'd you'd i mean you'd be talking
about something which i don't think has
been studied well at all which is
basically
so now you're talking about probably
based nash equilibrium analysis so here
these lower bounds are even for full
information okay so so but for revenue
presumably you'll be talking about based
nash equilibrium analysis you now have
to be talking about the optimization
problem which is not you know here here
the op division run was x post welfare
maximization what you're saying it would
be
um
you know bayesian the bayesian revenue
max maximizing auctions revenue and
you'd have to think about the
computability and the probability of
that problem
which
you know has been studied a little bit
but not a lot i don't think
but but but otherwise it should
translate so if you had negative results
for
computing the optimal expected revenue
that should actually translate into
something for price management
guarantees for simple auctions i think
yeah good question
so
i didn't i had a question earlier um
it's sort of on the technical side but
the uh severity result can you prove it
so there is a
sort of like
a specific technique that
works for
i don't know felt monetarily yes can you
prove it via an extension crm
can you prove it say here we have
extension theorem that you have for
exercise for example there is no known
way of doing it and the straightforward
way of trying get stuck at log m
so i don't totally know how to prove a
theorem that says no conceivable
smoothness type argument it could be
doable but i don't know how to formalize
that statement
but so certainly in their upper bound
they crucially use
the selection of these baseline
strategies for deviation in an
equilibrium dependent way so they look
at the equilibrium they say for this
equilibrium to say this particular
equilibrium is good we're going to use
these particular deviations and the
deviations depend on the equilibrium
and it's very clever how they use it and
it seems
it seems very hard to know how you
recapture their
factor two without
an equally clever idea but
i don't know
yeah
so if one could turn the feldman at all
upper bound into some kind of more
general extension theorem be super cool
i'm not sure but uh that that's possible
but it'll be really nice
it's i'm sorry if i missed this but
yesterday you talked a lot about even if
you can't find equilibria you have these
bonds even for no regret solutions right
uh how did that work with today's
results right so so it's a good question
so somehow this so the so here this
would really be immediate i mean this
would be basically trivial if
um
the lower you know if i just wanted to
say that worst case no regret equilibria
can't be very good because those are
polytone computable
right so so you know if you have an
equilibrium once you can then just
compute yourself in polynomial time
then it's clear that that is a the time
algorithm and so it has to obey all
these lower bounds so the technical
point here is saying that you know even
for
and a lot of frankly a lot of the price
of energy analyses it's interesting i
mean so
you can actually just study price of
energy bounds and complexity of
equilibrium sort of totally separately i
mean they're both super interesting
they're both really important but
progress on one doesn't seem to depend
on the other at all so a lot of this
price vanity machinery remains valid
even if the equilibria are kind of hard
to compute and of course then there's
always this worry it's like oh okay if
you know why why should well you know
why can't they just get optimal why
can't he clearly just be optimal if you
know if they're like super hard to
compute and so this all says no no no
they're really for optimization purposes
you know they're stuck in the same place
that algorithms are stuck
now of course once you switch back to
the upper bound side
right you're hoping to prove upper
bounds which are not just for maybe
mixed nash equilibria but for no regret
learners and so on right so so here on
the lower bound side we wanted to kind
of use the hardest equilibrium concepts
on the other hand side we want to use
the easiest equilibrium concepts
good question
okay i think we should take more
questions to the break and let's start
the speed talks at 340.
you